All right, welcome.
So today we are going to talk about my productivity setup and what I've done
with it. And we are going to talk about mainly my primary setup,
even though that I have my secondary setup all the way through the back,
but I didn't prepare anything for that one.
So we'll be talking about this setup.
I use this setup for my morning routine by watching this hunky man,
he helps me do my 10 minute stretches, which I've been actually doing every day.
And, uh, afterwards, before I start work, I do some higher intensity exercise.
It's only a five minute video, but you know, I'm working on my consistency.
First. I have a water bottle on my desk at all times.
It's actually a milk jug.
I use this because it's exactly eight cups of water,
which is what you need in a day. And I also use this because it's quite heavy.
So sometimes I accidentally do a bicep curl while I drink my
water, which is the most strength training I'll do in a day nowadays.
And then for my real job, uh, I work as a software engineer.
So I mostly use, uh, their internal tools, which I can't show,
but I'll use some are tools here for demo purposes.
So I have an ID in the middle, usually a terminal on the right,
maybe emails on the left,
some SQL editor or dashboards on the top monitor and then maybe
some black pink also for a music while I work.
It looks different depending on what I'm working on.
Sometimes I just chat with my coworkers the whole day about work stuff
for editing videos.
I have my bottom monitor open up premiere pro so I can see a
huge timeline. It makes editing real fast.
And then the top monitor for extra space to open folders, transfer files,
browse a web. I have everything I need. This setup is quite perfect.
The only thing missing is my talent.
When I make educational videos for Joe mCLASS,
I use this setup to edit animations like this one about time complexity.
And then for the top monitors, I usually have my script.
I can reference to when I do my voiceovers for the videos.
And then I also have my ID open to record myself,
coding the things I'm teaching. Uh, it could be something else.
It could be a SQL editor if I'm teaching SQL
and then for entertainment.
Anyways, let's talk about the gear now.
So the first thing you see here is the big monitor.
The name is actually a little bit complicated,
so I'm just going to leave it in the description. But, uh,
I know this one thing, it's a 79 inches.
I actually didn't buy it. LG just sent it to me. And when they sent it to me,
I thought it was quite overwhelming. Right? When I first started using it,
I thought it was way too big, but after 10 minutes, I got used to it.
It's actually the same as having two 16 by nine monitors,
except that you don't have the thing in between.
You can also use it as two separate monitors. So for example,
once I had this half of the monitor use the Nintendo switch and then this
half of the monitor would be connected to my computer.
So I could play video games while I work. But, uh,
I don't do that anymore cause I'm a big boy. All right. So if you look up,
you can see that we have the less big monitor, which is still pretty big.
So this one, LG also sent it to me.
It's pretty funny because I told them that I already have the big monitor.
I don't need another monitor,
but they told me that the LG Les big model was actually one of the
software. Engineer's favorite. Let's see more, create better. Do you all knew,
Oh gee, less big monitor,
more space for multitasking because we know you're definitely not working
during quarantine. That's okay. Your secret is safe with us.
Oh gee, Les big monitor. Perfect for quarantine. Anyways.
I think the true beauty of this setup is that when you combine these two
monitors, you get five perfectly sized panels,
20 inches. Yeah.
So five perfectly sized 20 inch panels that you can use for what
ever you want. That's the beauty of it. And that's probably my number one.
Favorite thing about this setup.
My second favorite thing about this setup is right here.
As you can see,
everything is connected via this USB-C cable.
This connects to two of my monitors, my speakers,
my mouse, my keyboard, everything. How did I do that? Well,
I'm glad you asked this cable is connected to this easy
GPU, which is extremely overpriced and totally not worth it.
That connects to my two monitors via USB-C and HTMI.
And then the speakers and the USB receivers for my keyboard and mouse would
connect to that monitor. So any laptop can immediately connect to all the,
just by using this one USB-C cable.
That's important for me because I have a work laptop and a personal laptop that
I talk frequently because I sell crack as a side hustle.
Speaking of crack,
no one in their right minds should buy this EGP view on Lester on something.
This is the black magic EG GPU, and there's nothing magical about it.
The only magic it does is it makes your money disappear.
It's just so expensive. Right?
I initially bought it for my Mac mini on this setup so I can record my videos of
me drawing and teaching for Joe mCLASS.
But instead I just bought a gaming computer, which is this one right here.
And it's just so much better. However, it's not all bad. Uh,
I did kind of salvage it because my work laptop, I don't know if you can see,
because my, because my work, because my work laptop,
Oh my God. Because my work laptop can't handle the big monitor,
unfortunately. Uh, but with the each GPU, it works great.
And you might ask, why don't you just request a better laptop from your company?
Well, I did.
I asked them for a better laptop and they told me that we will give you a better
laptop once you become a better employee. So, um,
so I guess I'll stick with the black magic then.
Okay. What's next? Okay. Yeah. So these are my boast speakers right here.
They're kind of far away.
I literally only bought these Bose speakers for this one thing,
this puck right here. So what this does is you could turn it on,
turn it off and then you could adjust the volume like this.
This is the only reason why I bought these speakers because now I can sit back,
relax and adjust the volume like this,
instead of reaching all the way here to adjust the volume and maybe
accidentally pulling my muscle.
My mouse is the MX master three a it has a lot of features
that I don't use.
[Inaudible].
Um, so I'll just say that it's a solid mouse. Okay. And then for my keyboard,
it's just the, uh, Mac keyboard, uh, nothing special.
These are the Bose headphones that I got expensed when I worked
for Facebook. Um, but they broke, right? The Bluetooth doesn't work.
The only way to make your work is to plug it in to the speakers.
But I don't want to get another one because they don't make them in these colors
anymore. And I love this color,
but unfortunately that means I have to use this wire like a barbarian. So,
Oh, last but not least my chair, this one.
So this is the, uh, Herman Miller M body. Uh,
it's really popular nowadays. Every YouTube has it. Every professional has it.
I think it's pretty good. Um, I don't know if it's worth the price though,
but uh, yeah,
I actually chose the colors so that it matches exactly like the
one on the website. Uh, except one thing though, uh, if you come below,
so as you can see, I pimped my wheels. Uh,
I made them translucent for 80 extra dollars and, um,
that's definitely not worth it. Yeah. All right. So here's something for you,
OCD people, if you look closely,
you'll realize that this monitor is a little bit shifted to the left,
maybe by like half an inch.
And also this whole setup is actually not even centered with my
art.
It was intentional because it's a metaphor for life that things are not
going to be perfectly aligned for you.
You can never plan for the unexpected and you have to be okay with
imperfection.
Another reason was because I didn't have my ruler with me at the time.
Thank you so much for watching.
Just want to say that Joe mCLASS has a lot of new videos with new animations
that are really, really cool. And also we just completed the SQL course.
So if you're into data analytics, data science,
or even just as a software engineer, SQL course could be for you. All right.
You should check it out@joemclass.com. See ya.